[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Johnny Steinberg a South African
writer and scholar from the University
of Oxford he is at Yale as a visiting
scholar and the Council on African
Studies at the Macmillan Centre
professor Steinberg is the author of
several books that explore South African
people and institutions in the wake of
the transition to democracy two of them
Midlands about the murder of a white
South African farmer and two the number
a biography of a prison gangster when
South Africa's premier nonfiction award
The Sunday Times Alan Payton award today
we'll talk with Professor Steinberg
about his book project on Nelson and
Winnie Mandela's marriage welcome
professor Steinberg
thanks man let's begin with an overview
of the project tell us about it well
it's about South Africa's most famous
and iconic marriage probably between its
two most recognized people both
larger-than-life
both played formidable roles in in
recent South African history and were
married to one another and I guess the
premise of the book is that what
happened in their marriage and what
happened in in their respective public
careers is is very closely connected so
it's an exploration of marriage and two
political lives and and how they grew
from one another mm-hm
now I know you've looked at a lot of
different people and institutions in
South African and have written books
about some of them so I'm curious what
led you to Winnie and Nelson quite
different to anything I've written
before I've usually written about
ordinary anonymous people and try to
tell big stories through ordinary lives
and in a way this is the opposites this
is to try to show how the
all textures and life emerge from what
big people have done so in a sense it's
an inverse of whatever was done before
and and and a challenge that I'm looking
forward to but what what struck in your
mind okay I'm gonna I'm going to look at
their marriage how did you get to that
point I'm curious well at the beginning
I was actually embarking upon a book
about Nelson Mandela only and a short
way into the research realized that it
was quite difficult to tell the story
about him without also telling a story
about her from his perspective in the
spectrum of his politics and his career
I think that his marriage to her was was
formative and shaped so much about what
he did in the world and realizing that
the marriage was so much part of the
story you know it dawned on me that I
should write a book about the marriage
she's also you know an enormous league
controversial figure but an
extraordinary figure yes probably the
best-known South African woman and and I
wanted to give her story it's do I
didn't just want to tell a story about
him I thought that for a number of
reasons the story about the marriage was
the right one right right and how do you
get at the research because obviously a
marriage is a very private kind of thing
how do you get into that to see what
their marriage was really like what are
you doing to kind of do the research
well one very important source the
letters that they wrote to one another
he was in jail for 27 years and and
during that time of separation they
wrote to one another a great deal and
letters are not a transparent window
into what somebody is feeling or into a
relationship but they tell you a great
deal and some of those letters are are
immensely powerful some of them are some
of the greatest of letters ever written
you know between two people who were
passionately in love they they were only
together a short time they met in 1957
married a year later three years later
he was on the run in in hiding and then
in prison and so there were these three
years of passion and romance which were
receding into memory into history
you know they were thinking about them
all the time more and more nostalgically
more and more idea idealistically and
all of this is contained in this very
powerful correspondence so that's one
source another are you know I'm looking
at I'm looking for all the remaining
people who knew them at every stage of
their marriage from when they met in the
late 1950s there they were both very
striking very beautiful people he was a
very famous person when they got
together with caused a splash they they
were treated like celebrities in a way
that no other South African political
figure ever was there really there were
the beginnings of political Liberty of
real glamour and people remember them
very vividly I'm also talking to all
there are many people who were
imprisoned with Nelson Mandela and the
dozens perhaps hundreds of people who
came into contact with when he and knew
something of her personally during the
years that Nelson was in prison so lots
and lots of work to do okay so I know
you open with their courtship and you
know they basically told the same story
of how they met but you seem to think
there was some deception there so let's
talk about that a little bit their story
versus the reality well it's amazing
that by the end of their lives they
disagreed on almost everything but but
one of the few things they agreed on was
how they met and and the story that they
agreed upon wasn't entirely true the
story that they both told was a very
classically gendered story of a of an
older powerful man and a young naive and
beautiful woman he was 38 when they met
he was a lawyer at that stage there were
only 60 black lawyers in South Africa it
was a big deal to be a lawyer and he was
also increasingly becoming the most
famous anti-apartheid activist in the
country he drove a very flashy
flamboyant car a green Oldsmobile he
wore very very expensive tailored suits
he was it was a great public figure she
was much younger than him she was 22
years old she had just come to
Johannesburg having had a rural
upbringing and she was stupendously
beautiful that's what everybody
remembers about her
and the story is of an an older man
seducing a younger woman he felt her
beauty she fell for his power and an old
gendered story rolls on but if you look
at the letters that he was writing to
her from prison ten years later you can
see that something else was actually
going on you know at one point he says I
don't know if I'm free to remind you of
this but you actually quoted me you went
after me in other letters one discovers
that she was seeing somebody else at the
same time was playing the two men of
each other so she was a much more savvy
powerful self-confident person than the
old story suggests and it seems as if
something very special was happening
between them which they perhaps didn't
have the words for and that was the idea
of the marriage as itself being a
spectacle the political spectacle and
you have to transport yourself back to
1950 South Africa to to see the enormous
political import the political power
have seemed too well-heeled enormous ly
confidence beautiful black people
together it sent a political message
which which they understood and which
many others perhaps didn't so I think
even in these very very earliest years
they were forging a political
partnership and it was hidden by the old
gendered story do you think that they
knew that from from the very first
beginnings that they would be held as an
example I think it was more question of
intuition and instincts than the real
knowledge that this would become the
country's most famous and important
political marriage I think that they
they both just had an in in a to ative
sense of political celebrity and it's
it's deep seriousness and it's deep
importance and that's part of what drew
them together so let's characterize
their marriage for us I mean they spent
30 years apart three years initially
together than 30 years apart I'm curious
how you sustain that kind of marriage
did was she able to visit him at all in
prison well at the beginning the contact
between them was very restricted she
didn't see him at all for the
couple of years then she was only
allowed to visit him every six months
very very briefly in circumstances where
waters were listening in on their
conversations and watching them there
were permitted to write to each other
with very short letters and which senses
would read first so for many many years
there was no contact between them in
privacy at all and the result is that
they they often had to speak to one
another in code and part of my work is
to try and decipher this code and and
and get a sense of what they were really
saying to one another one of the most
interesting was was was about fidelity
he became aware fairly early that she
was sleeping with others and and had to
decide how to respond to this but that
was not public knowledge I imagine well
it was the subject of a great deal of
gossip in the liberation movement many
people around them were speaking about
it the security police made sure that he
knew they wanted to hurt him they wanted
him to know anything that might damage
him and there are a couple of letters
where you can see him
subterranean you away sort of between
the lines saying I understand that
you're a young woman and that I'm away
indefinitely but let us remain committed
to one another politically you can
always almost see the sublimation
happening as sexual fidelity being
replaced by a political fidelity I don't
think he it was ever comfortable with it
but I think that he understood it right
right and I am curious so if that is
going on in its and there's gossip about
their marriage and he is still in prison
what was it like in South Africa in
terms of that partnership how was the
outside world looking at their marriage
well what became of the marriage was was
is really when he is doing she could
have disappeared into obscurity the
South African government made her life
absolute hell she'd put her children in
school and they'd put pressure on the
headmaster to expel them she had a
career as a social worker they banned
her which restricted her movement to
such an extent that she had to give up
her job so she lost her livelihood she
lost her capacity but her children in
school
she very bravely started underground
work and they caught it for that and
threw her in prison she was in solitary
confinement she wasn't person altogether
of 18 months in solitary confinement for
about nine months of that she was beaten
and tortured and the more they went
after her the stronger she became and by
the late 1970s she was a quite unique
figure she was the only figure inside
the country who could say I'm a member
of the ANC I can talk for them see
everybody else was in exile or in prison
and she kept his memory alive
so in a way that the marriage became as
famous as it was largely due to her
courage due to her continual recognition
that their marriage was an enormously
powerful symbol than that she would keep
putting herself in the marriage out
there she she carried it for many years
and they did have two children they did
have two children and their lives were
also made incredibly difficult by by
these circumstances in 1977 when he was
banned the police arrived at her house
one night through all her worldly
positions on a track and and drove her
off into a remote town in the middle of
nowhere which she didn't speak local
language she was given a small two-room
house and one of her kids went to to
live with her in those circumstances
then went off to boarding school so so
the kids had a watch you know both of
their parents being in prisons one of
their parents being banished being
separated from them all the time so they
could be educated it was a very very
difficult childhood for both of them yes
a very difficult life for all of them so
when Nelson got out of jail what
happened well they'd been a great deal
of controversy around Winnie in in two
years preceding Nelson's released from
prison she defied her banning order to
Brantford this town in this rural town
that she went to and went back to swear
so to her home at a time when there were
uprisings across South Africa against
the party it's and the epicenter was in
Soweto and she went back into the thick
of that
said things and did things that were
enormous ly controversial right and in
the year preceding his release Mandela
was really faced with a choice about
whether to be loyal to her or whether to
distance himself from her and took this
decision to stand by her and when he
walked out of prison on the 11th of
February 1990 it was holding her hand
and they both showed their fists the
world they were together their United
and strong and then their marriage
unraveled over the following two years
right it was short-lived yeah and I
guess that's given all that it happened
over the previous three decades and
their very limited capacity to come
together and talk things through and
work things out and in a way it's not
surprising they'd both been through a
thousand lifetimes right they've been
through the extraordinary they both
lived and experienced such extreme lives
and when he was released they had to
move straight into the limelight they
were both working 18 20 hours a day
you know living at a very high level
very hard for a relationship to survive
right right I mean the separation and
then the intense scrutiny I would
imagine it would be tougher any marriage
I am wondering because they did end up
divorcing as you had said their values
kind of also grew apart too can you talk
a little bit about that well it's coming
to say that's that their political
values are now directly opposed to one
another you know Nelson Mandela is is
famous for forgiveness for
reconciliation and for saying we know
what happened in the past but if we're
going to build a future we have to find
a way of putting it behind us when he is
famous for saying that she doesn't
forget any of the hurt that she hasn't
forgiven any of the hurt and that she
will not so yes in a sense their their
political values drifted you know I
think the fact that they're both
speaking to an eternal question which is
what do you do about the past do you
forgive what happened there you know
that's that's a question that's that we
all face all the time and that's what
they addressed and I think that's
as a result they'll both be remembered
for a long time they were both speaking
to to a universal eternal question and
maybe an honorable question and they
both gave such definitive such powerful
answers mm-hmm
and the sense that these two opposing
answers were were housed in one marriage
and in what happened between two people
makes the very attractive marriage to
two rights both attractive marriage with
somebody who writes about politics to
write about right right
and after they divorced did they still
work together on some level politically
no they became increasingly estranged
you know he when Nelson Mandela became
president in May 1994 Winnie Mandela was
given the junior position in cabinets
but was fired from it quite quickly and
and from there on they drifted further
and further apart but after the Nelson
died when he became very close to to the
leaders of a new radical populist
opposition movement so she were made a
member of the ANC but increasingly
skeptical mmm-hmm so what do you think
their partnerships mark left on South
Africa well in a sense you know they
they bookends the the unfinished
business the unfinished controversies of
of the way apartheid ended in South
Africa today you know there's an
enormous debate which go is fiercer
every day about whether the ANC conceded
too much about whether white people got
away with too much and and in the sense
those two are emblems of that very very
live debate which will probably a debate
to last for another generation or two
and they will keep symbolizing us okay
well thank you very much for being here
with us and sharing your work thanks
it's been a pleasure for more
information about Professor Steinberg
and his research please visit our
website at macmillan report yale.edu be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
whitney and betty macmillan center for
international
and area studies at yeah
you